a promise represents a value that is
unknown now that may become known in the
future in other words in asynchronous
value think of it like a ride hailing
app when you request a ride the driver
makes a promise to pick you up while
you're waiting the ride is pending in
the future if all goes according to plan
the driver will resolve to pick you up
then take you somewhere
at which point your ride has been
fulfilled but in some cases the driver
might reject your ride in which case
you'll need to catch one somewhere else
either way the original request is now
finally settled as a developer he might
want to create a promise to represent an
asynchronous value but more often than
not you'll be consuming promises to use
the result of an asynchronous operation
in your code on the Left we're making
promises on the right we're using them
when constructed a promise starts off in
a pending state it's your job to define
a callback function called an executor
that defines when to resolve or reject
the promise this is where you would kick
off your asynchronous work on the other
side the consumer of the promise has
called it's then method it's waiting for
the asynchronous value to be fulfilled
when that happens it will call this
function with the value as its argument
we fulfill the promise by calling
resolve but there's always the
possibility of an exception in that case
we can reject the promise and send the
error back down to the consumer which
can use the catch method and an entirely
different function for handling
exceptions and if you just want to run
some code no matter what you can use
finally to handle both possibilities all
of these methods return promises which
means they can be chained together to
handle multiple asynchronous operations
in a row this has been JavaScript
promises in 100 seconds thanks for
watching and also make sure to follow my
brand new Instagram account for even
more content on this topic I will see
you in the next one
[Music]